I've said before, we just can't allow the
American right wing to hold the monopoly on
so-called papers
criticism because as I've pointed out many,
many times, the right uses patriotism as a
tool it uses of military veterans as a prop.
It uses law enforcement as a political posturing
tool and Donald Trump specifically has also
used nine 11 to try to prop himself up and
truly vile and disgusting ways and once again
he seems unable to help himself.
He gave a brief statement yesterday announcing
that the nine 11 victim compensation fund
has been signed, which is good.
He could not help himself from saying I was
down there too talking about ground zero and
nine 11 take a look at this.
A few moments.
I will sign the nine 11 victims compensation
fund.
This law makes permanent the financial support
for families who lost precious loved ones
as a result of September 11th attacks.
It also provides pensions for those who are
suffering from cancer and other illnesses
stemming from the toxic debris they were exposed
to in the aftermath of the attacks.
Many of those affected were firefighters,
police officers and other first responders.
And I was down there also, but I'm not considering
myself a first responder, but I was down there.
I spent a lot of time down there with you.
Trump has lied so much about nine 11 and his
role and being down there and his company's
role.
Here's Trump saying that he helped clear rubble.
Everyone who helped clear the rubble.
I was there and I watched and I helped a little
bit, but I want to tell you, those people
were amazing.
Clearing the rubble, trying to find the additional
lines.
You didn't know what was gonna come down on
all of us and they handled it.
I was down there helping a little and you
didn't know what was going to come down on
us.
I guess he's saying, uh, which is a total
lie.
And this is not just a liar, but this is a
disgusting liar.
This is the closest you can get to sort of
stolen valor, which applies specifically to
the military without it actually being stolen
valor.
And if you want Donald Trump's real genuine
reaction to nine one 11, it's on video.
Look no further than at what Trump said when
he called into some television station after
nine 11 thanks to nine 11 resulting in the
destruction of the Twin Towers, Donald realized
that his building in Lower Manhattan was apparently
the tallest one left standing in that neighborhood.
A really stupid accomplishment.
But that's where Donald Trump's mind went.
And if you don't believe me, we have the clip.
Take a look at this.
You have one of the landmark buildings down
in the financial district, 40 Wall Street.
Uh, did you have any damage or did you know
what's happened down there?
Well, it was an amazing phone call.
I Made 40 Wall Street actually was the second
tallest building in downtown Manhattan.
And it was actually before the World Trade
Center was the tallest.
And then when they built the World Trade Center,
it became known as the second tallest.
And now it's the tallest.
This is a despicable person.
I mean, truly this is someone who is completely
a moral.
I was down there too.
He says to nine 11 victims, first responders
there, families who actually did suffer on
nine 11 and who can't even afford healthcare
now, which is why we need to even pass this
bill to begin with.
And then just remember the long track record
that Donald Trump has.
He promised to donate $10,000 to the nine
11 victims, which for a guy as rich as him
is nothing, and then he never actually donated
it, but he kept taking credit for it publicly.
Trump has claimed that he had employees that
he sat down to work at ground zero.
There's no evidence of that whatsoever at
all.
Trump said he watched people jumping out of
the windows of the World Trade Center on nine
11 by looking out of his window.
That's not true.
Just that there's no evidence of that.
Trump claimed he lost hundreds of friends
in nine 11 has not been able to name a single
one.
And then of course his lies extend beyond
just his sort of personal delusions of grander.
He also has said that he saw a thousand Muslim
celebrating in New Jersey or something, which
is of course untrue, widely debunked and he's
been called out about that in the past.
There are lies and there are lies and these
are lies that are particularly gross and disgusting.
Lie about the size of your crowd as he often
has.
Okay.
This is another level altogether.
It's truly beyond the Pale and what fundamentally
is at the core of this is that nothing can
be about just other people.
If Donald Trump is giving someone an award,
it partially has to be about how he had the
great sense to give them the award, how he
is going to take heat from someone because
he has chosen to give this award.
I mean there is nothing that Donald Trump
is unable to make about himself and this is
yet another one of those examples.